you know what Dave Thomas the the late
date Dave Thomas and Ray Kroc lived in
the same Community here in Fort
Lauderdale did I know that yeah before
they passed away both of them lived here
great great I'm glad you Croc's my hero
yeah great crowd behind the Arches John
love
great great book Crux the guy that
figured it out if that franchisee
doesn't make money then the mother ship
is worthless I mean he looked at
everything from a a franchisee
perspective he used to charge the
um the franchisees like a half percent
royalty wouldn't even cover his overhead
on supervising it and it wasn't until
Harry stubborn came along in uh I think
late 70s and the 80s and came up with a
real estate play where we'll you know
we'll buy the land build the building
take ten percent he was the business guy
Harry stubborn was the guy that figured
out the economics but Ray was a
salesperson he was the vision he was a
guy that said we can turn this into
something big
he was a multi-mixer he was a milkshake
blender salesman for God's sake when he
met I was saying Ray Croc you must have
loved that movie the founder with
Michael Keaton I mean that you how many
times have you seen that movie I've seen
it
um um a couple times I don't think it
really Embraces what Croc was all about
um his his I mean he lost all his
friends at his country club because they
wouldn't live up to his qscnv he was
fanatical about quality service and
cleanliness and value
um in a character you know I mean he
liked to have a good time but Croc
um his I mean remember Croc uh
McDonald's what fit 1955-1960 Hell
Burger Chef had been around 20 30 years
White Castle been around 20 30 40 years
a Burger King
um Burger Queen all these Concepts were
way before McDonald's he came 20 30 40
years check uh check my mom the king
came out before I know Burger Chef did
so yeah but but Checkers say McDonald's
wasn't the OG that we think it is as
today we think that's the original
McDonald's you know a hamburger joint
yeah but he by the way he's right Burger
King came out before McDonald's wow I
didn't even know that did you know that
no I hadn't had no idea McDonald's was
late to the party and Croc still kicked
all them I love that yeah he kicked the
ruts what kind of relate to that do you
kind of relate to the fact that you know
Pizza a lot of these guys have been
around for a while and you came out and
well the thing we're most proud of is
our team you know our people in our
product and our team
um but remember in our category there's
some forty thousand independent
pizzerias so you when I came along you
had Domino's Little Caesars and pizza
you had the three three big players now
all 40 000 independent pizzerias are
wired like us they they want to get they
want to be John they want to get through
that window of opportunity and out of
the 40 000 we've been the only one that
can come out of that horse racing and
get to the top four we did it and that's
just because the great team effort and
great product and I got to tell you we
leaned on the book um behind the Arches
by John love pretty hard did you did you
ever meet Ray or no no I've been up to
Oakbrook
third University
um they go through the museum I mean
that the office up there has actually
has a McDonald's in it with a pub
because he liked to drink beer after uh
the day was over but you know
um your quality is only as good as your
consistency
very systematic guy everything was about
system with that everything and I don't
know when it was one time McDonald's
tested out creating a pineapple Burger I
don't know if you remember that story
yeah so he said one guy came out and
said let's sell a pineapple Burger you
know how long it lasted like apparently
lasted like a couple days people hated
it yeah it's probably not a good idea so
they would test some of the products it
would come out and then boom Ray one
time said 90 percent of the best ideas
that we got at McDonald's came from
bottom up would you would you agree with
that like was that also cultural with
you guys were a lot of your operators
would say hey John what if we do this
and what if we test this and what if we
do that
well I I think you always got to look
for new and better ways the McRib
sandwich was a franchisee idea the Egg
McMuffin was a franchisee of McDonald's
um but I'm sure forever one or two great
ideas they may probably have a thousand
bad
but when you start running your business
from the c-suite and you're not out in
with the franchisee store level
um
the suppliers if you're not out looking
on what's going on in the real world and
learning then you're not going to
innovate and get better the first you
all just ordered some pizzas from Jets
and Papa John's when I walked in and the
driver of Papa John's hadn't busted me
yet and I asked the guy I said hey is
the pizza any good Papa John's he goes
no not really and I was like floored he
has no clue who you are yet no he well
he did after about three or four minutes
can you imagine how fun that's hilarious
and I go really he goes yeah it's not
too good I said you eat Eagles I don't
eat it but I'm like you know three or
four years ago a driver would have never
set our product is something he wouldn't
Pride home a driver's seat driver Papa
John's just told me in the lobby says
you know it's not very good pizza so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
foreign
[Music]